you're going talking before you just met
mics yeah and actually work with them
yet yeah
now you guys had a chance to work with
the other half of it Heroes for Hire
they call yeah what's up in like a
change of that matrix which can you do
it all really great the it feels
effortless I kind of feel that when
you've got a duo like this which is so
hyped up by the fans there's a there's a
there's a worry that it may be too
oversold and you may be kind of trying
too hard to create that that cannot in
that spark but actually between me and
Mike we get on really world it's a
really great energy between the two of
our actors but also much so much fun and
but then also as the characters in the
way the scenes are written it's really
interesting the way they're doing it and
it's a real slow build it feels very
real and very just dynamic and honest
and some of the scenes of defenders
would with mike has been my favorite so
far because after this Danny be able to
sitting with the darker cynical side of
the Marvel Netflix universe yes but he
could get some in a lot of trouble okay
gotcha yes a lot of people out there too
also by the time we get to defenders and
this is so far ahead now and we've gone
through it takes place several months
after irons it's a you know with a
change here is a change
Danny isn't as Danny's a little bit more
world aware by the end of iron is
because of the the things that happen to
him so he still he still got up to Miss
Emily's goggle that drive but it's not
so independencies not so naive as you
heavy is imminent in society there are
your father tell me who you are
I'm behind Danny ran comes back to New
York after being gone for 15 years at my
building fellas my shoes
he believes it he'll be received with
open arms I'm Danny ran in a way a long
time the first year realizes that the
world's changed what joy his childhood
friend joy an awards an hour
billionaires running his father's
corporation sorry but I'm calling
security boy no it's me they don't
believe at em to begin with
standing brand dead but don't do this
Danny just wants to do the right thing
but he has this fire in him
if
where'd you train carefully get there
from here
we find out he spent 15 years in a
monastery training to become this
warrior about how you got that tattoo
not exactly a tattoo its market the iron
this horse that runs through the
universe the fire of the fit and Danny
cannon ignites it
Danny has been old his whole life
there's a mythological dark force in the
world
and he didn't really believe that they
were real nor they are very real if
infested Rand all these people have
their own agendas even though he's good
in his back there will always be forces
gathering against you disguised as a
friend slipping past you as a stranger
they are everywhere you know who the
good guys here to be it's really fun to
go on that journey with the character
embrace your destiny the show just hits
you full throttle
it is no place for the eye and I have a
vision of total victory and nothing out
[Music]
you
hey everybody what's up Danny ran
droppin bombs about Heroes for Hire
defender stuff let's break this down one
of the biggest takeaways is that
defenders picks up six months later in
the timeline after the end of iron fist
so if you're new to the channel welcome
I do Marvel videos every week there's
going to be a ton of Iron Fist stuff
dropping really soon be sure to
subscribe to get everything
there's a giveaway going on that I'll
explain at the end of the video but
Danny Rand and Luke Cage the really
interesting thing we're talking about
here is for higher stuff in this they're
talking about the dynamics between them
the showrunner for season 1 of iron fist
is actually doing the Marvel Inhumans TV
show which is airing later this fall
meaning that he's not working on iron
fist anymore
so that could either mean that they're
actually planning on doing a legit
Heroes for Hire TV show in the future or
they could just hire another showrunner
they did the exact same thing with
daredevil season 2 they had a different
showrunner come on and I know a lot of
you are asking about that daredevil
teaser new theory shed light on Lost
City so they're talking about Kunlun so
in addition to all this cool Heroes for
Hire stuff it sounds like they might be
teasing some immortal weapons stuff for
future Iron Fist seasons should they
happen and I think that they will I
think they'll probably just wind up
bringing that different showrunner on
but the way they explained in the
trailer he's been gone 15 years the
actual city of Kunlun only appears every
10 here so you can only get back there
every 10 years
Kunlun is one of the capital cities of
heaven there are a bunch of them in the
comics what happens is is that every 88
years you know just like Kunlun only
appears every 10 years every 88 years
they all appear at the same time the
immortal weapon of each of the cities
fights and different places on the earth
there was actually an Iron Fist comic
book series called the immortal weapons
so I might actually do a longer video
for that because it's actually a really
cool storyline crane mother really big
character that we've seen a couple times
already she's one of the rulers of one
of the other capital cities of heaven so
I'm also guessing that that giant
never-ending hole in the ground during
daredevil season 2 also has something to
do with this larger plotline with the
immortal weapons in the stuff that's
going on during defenders now I know
they call it street-level but it's
actually getting pretty crazy because
Sigourney Weaver the villain of
defenders might end up being typhoid
mary but i really like the way the Finn
Jones is teasing iron fist
compared to the other defenders
dynamic in the group like he says his
optimism gets him into trouble a lot
that probably means with other defenders
characters as well as just regular
randos on the street too like he
probably gets in a lot of street fights
just because he's trusting people too
much doesn't totally understand what's
going on because he's been away from
society for so long like Jessica Jones
is probably the most cynical member of
the defenders I could totally see his
optimism pissing her off and her just
punching him Hulk style through one of
the doors you have to remember that she
is super strong just like Luke Cage she
doesn't have impenetrable skin an iron
fist can totally take it he's not extra
strong but he can strengthen himself and
he can use his Chi to heal himself extra
fast but seriously though this is
actually going to be the lightest of the
Netflix series they're all pretty
serious like the stuff that went on
during Luke Cage was pretty hardcore
think about where his mind space is
right now he's back in sigue prison and
he knows that he's innocent
but he's doing the time anyway so he is
in a really bad place but it sounds like
they're going to get to that Heroes for
Hire dynamic pretty fast even though I
mean he's still going to be really
pissed off when he first gets out of
prison there's probably going to happen
over the course of the first episode or
two because I don't think it's going to
be a full 13 episodes like Iron Fist in
the other Netflix series it's like a
smaller mini series but the episodes are
even bigger so they're spending more
money so I think that's part of the idea
is if they do fewer but there is more
per episode well let me know in the
comments what do you guys most excited
for for all this I know we're ramping up
for defenders even though we haven't
even gotten iron fist yet defenders is
dropping in this summer I'm going to say
early June until they announce the
premiere date they'll confirm it after
iron fist comes out and for those are
you asking about trailers and stuff like
that they'll totally drop a teaser at
the end of iron fist because it's coming
so quickly it's not as I just going to
roll up to June to be like here you go
you're all the episodes they've actually
done a weird thing with the way they
market the shows now because they've had
a couple seasons I feel like they're
spending less money on traditional
marketing and they're relying more on
word-of-mouth people like me that make
videos for this kind of stuff saying hey
everybody watch this it's coming on this
day be sure to check it out so we're
just getting to the point where Netflix
is now just slowly eating traditional
television so even in the next like five
to ten years you'll see everybody
streaming their series Netflix style
even though TV
itself is never going to go away but as
for longevity of the Netflix stuff they
tend to overspend on their series so
these won't go on forever but I think at
least five seasons and I think at least
like three or four big defender style
team ups they have to do like a couple
seasons of each joke between the
defender series and because there are so
many defenders now you have four
defenders then you have Punisher so
that's five Marvel Netflix series not
including defenders each year that you
could do if you wanted to which feels
like a lot for them so what might end up
happening is depending on the success of
the defenders is that they'll wait like
two years before releasing another
defender season and you're starting to
get crazy hype about with each new
season after defenders because they've
introduced all the characters they'll
probably start doing the Marvel movie
thing where you do bigger crossovers
instead of just doing self-contained
seasons with just that character you'll
see Iron Fist pop up during Luke Cage
you'll see daredevil pop up during the
Punisher series all the kind of crazy
stuff that they use to not do as much
the big name of the game now even the
x-men movies are going to be doing a lot
of the crossover stuff that Marvel's
been teasing like you see Iron Man pop
up in spider-man you'll start to see
that happen with all of the comic book
genre across movies TV shows and I think
it'll make everything just a lot better
just looking for really awesome
character interactions so what's going
to happen next is I have a new Deadpool
2 video to post they've been talking a
lot about x-force is basically Deadpool
and x-force so I'll post that tomorrow
there's also a whole bunch more comic
book stuff I'll try to get some new game
of throne there's a new round of the
Doctor Strange giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video congratulations to
last week's winner Punisher 2021 please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details so that Deadpool will post
Saturday morning there's also some
really cool stuff happening this weekend
what you wait for that to post you can
click here for all my other Iron Fist
videos and you can click here to learn
all about sword Ragnarok
thank you so much for watching let's
high five I'll see you guys in the next
video